sehr ernst so bewertet die
bundesregierung die korona lage über
beherbergungs verbote während der
herbstferien wird immer schärfer
diskutiert neue russland sanktionen nach
dem giftanschlag auf den kremlkritiker
nawal nähe bringt die eu strafmaßnahmen
auf den weg ein jahr im eis die
polarstern kehrt von ihrer
arktis-expedition zurück mit jeder menge
daten für die klimaforschung
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen bei
den 19 uhr nachrichten am montag für den
sport ist wie der arbeitnehmer an meiner
seite einen schönen abend auch von mir
bisher sind die meisten menschen in
deutschland in der korona krise den
maßnahmen der regierenden gefolgt doch
das sogenannte beherbergungs verbot für
reisende aus risikogebieten sorgt gerade
jetzt während der herbstferien für eine
heftige kontroverse
vor allem tourismus und gastgewerbe
kritisieren die auflagen für heute ließ
schaaf ein verbot gäste aufzunehmen gibt
es in zwölf bundesländern allerdings
meist nur dann wenn kein gültiger corona
test vorliegt gültig heißt nicht älter
als 48 stunden mancherorts genügt auch
ein attest andreas köhlers berichtet
als die mit der krise befassten minister
am mittag das kanzleramt verlassen sind
sie sich einig so kann es nicht
weitergehen
die entwicklung der infektionszahlen
dramatisch die antwort der bundesländer
widersprüchlich und die kritik daran
unüberhörbar am streit um die
sogenannten beherbergungs verbote passt
dem bund überhaupt nicht es ist diese 16
mal unterschiedliche regelung für
innerdeutsche reisen jedenfalls
akzeptanzproblem auslöst und deswegen
ist aus meiner sicht ganz ganz wichtig
ist dass wir am mittwoch mit dem
ministerpräsidenten auch einheitliche
legen ihr kommt der druck auf die
befürworter des übernachtungs verbots
wie auf den bayerischen
ministerpräsidenten wächst nicht nur aus
anderen ländern auch aus dem eigenen wie
wird die deutschlandweit haben bewiesen
dass sowohl in der gastronomie als auch
die hoteliers in den hotels die
maßnahmen so aufgestellt haben dass
keine infektionen dort weiter gegeben
wurden und vor diesem hintergrund stellt
sich die frage wo ist das risiko dass in
den risikogebieten wie hier in köln nun
nicht mehr nur ankommende aus dem
ausland sondern auch abreisende ins
inland getestet werden bringt deren
systeme an die grenzen
also es ist in der tat sehr kompliziert
in der praxis weil man ja tagesaktuell
zum teil stündlich aktuell gucken muss
was es jetzt neues risikogebiet auch im
ausland an hat sich das ja andauernd so
ernstes der streit dass die
ministerpräsidenten am mittwoch nicht
mehr per video reden wollen sondern zu
im kanzleramt antreten werden schauen
wir auf die konkreten auswirkungen des
beherbergungs verbots auf urlauber und
gastgeber bernd mosebach berichtet aus
mecklenburg vorpommern wo die regeln am
strengsten sind und urlauber auch mit
negativen test noch in quarantäne müssen
der rostocker hotelier christoph krause
bittet um verständnis wer aus einem
risikogebiet anreisen bild bleibt besser
gleich zu hause
trotz corona test mindestens fünf tage
quarantäne drohen die meisten gäste
haben verstanden und studieren also auf
der einen seite leben wir von den
touristen sind auf sie angewiesen und
wollen natürlich möglichst viele
empfangen auf der anderen seite dass wir
natürlich auch selbst das wäre richtig
sauber arbeiten müssen dass wir keine
fehler machen wirken und unterstützen
deshalb auch die strecken der in
mecklenburg vorpommern
diese quarantäne regeln gelten bereits
hatte erst ein corona welle werden jetzt
wieder aktuell besonders für hotels mit
vielen gästen aus risikogebieten ein
harter schlag
die aktuelle situation mit berlin als
hauptquelle markt mit einem buches
anteil von gut 40 prozent aktuellen
herbstferien durchaus auch noch darüber
ist sehr sehr schwierig und wir müssen
klar sagen dass wir nach dem locker und
jetzt erstmalig wieder auch
wirtschaftlich deutlich um sicheres
fahrwasser zu steuern
die derzeit hohe nachfrage könnte die
stornierung und allerdings teilweise
wieder ausgleichen
die landesregierung verteidigt ihre
linie
wir haben bereits im mai darum gebeten
dass wir bundesweit regeln wie sich
hotspot zu verhalten haben das ist
bisher nicht erfolgt deshalb müssen wir
als tourismusland selbst regeln
aufstellen und so müssen alle urlauber
die aus einem risikogebiet kommen und
nicht gleich studieren zum test ich
finde das total angewiesen alles gut
jeder muss seinen teil beitragen
herbstferien 2020 für viele eine
geduldsprobe
die strikten maßnahmen sind wir haben es
gehört folge immer weiter steigender
corona zahlen
das gilt auch für die neuinfektionen im
wochenschnitt in den vergangenen sieben
tagen haben sich täglich 3530 menschen
neu mit dem virus angesteckt gestern lag
der wert bei 3350 was bringen maßnahmen
wie beherbergungs verbot oder
sperrstunde diese fragen stellen wir
einem virologen in einem zdf- heute live
um 19 uhr 30 auf zdf heute.de und in
unserer app in sachen corona stehen die
briten am scheideweg so eindringlich
schlug am wochenende ein englischer
experte alarm tatsächlich explodieren
gerade die infektionszahlen vor allem im
norden englands etwa in liverpool auf
100000 einwohner kamen dort in einer
woche 600 ansteckungen in manchester
oder nottingham sieht es ähnlich aus mit
einem drei stufen system will prämie
johnson jetzt noch schlimmeres
verhindern
andreas stamm
22 uhr england an diesem wochenende
corona sperrstunde für pubs und
restaurants die party geht trotzdem
weiter
obwohl sich höchstens sechs personen
privat treffen dürfen drinnen wie
draußen ein spontanes cricket spieler
auf der straße symbolisch fürs scheitern
der geltenden maßnahmen erst waren nur
die jüngeren infiziert doch die party
der sommer der freiheiten sei vorbei
erklärt englands oberster mediziner
china haben nun mehr patienten mit krone
in den krankenhäusern als ende märz als
die regierung den nationalen lockdown
verkündeten
wenn wir nichts tun wird die zahl der
tot und nicht erträglich der plan der
regierung ein drei stufensystem soll das
virus nun eindämmen von den aktuell
geltenden maßnahmen über das komplette
verbot privater treffen bis zur
schließung von papst restaurants oder
friseurin reich der maßnahmenkatalog je
nachdem wie stark corona in einer region
grassiert ich habe überhaupt keine
freude daran diesen geschäften weitere
restriktionen aufzubürden fielen die
alles dafür getan hatten um sicher
wieder öffnen zu können
und ich will menschen nicht davon
abhalten spaß zu haben aber wir müssen
handeln um leben zu retten
ab mittwoch gilt vor allem für städte im
norden wie etwa liverpool stufe 3 für
viele pubs und restaurants könnte es das
aus bedeuten noch verhandeln betroffene
bürgermeister mit der regierung über
finanzhilfen während im frühjahr
errichtete corona not krankenhäuser die
anweisung erhalten vorbereiten auf die
folgen der zweiten welle sollte was
virologen befürchten
der drei stufen plan scheitern der
österreichischen skiort ischgl gilt als
einer der ersten europäischen hotspots
in der korona krise jetzt hat eine
expertenkommission aufgearbeitet was im
märz dort alles schief gelaufen ist
so hätte etwa der betrieb der seilbahnen
und skipässe einen tag früher
eingestellt werden können
außerdem sei die quarantäne mangelhaft
vorbereitet worden
gäste seien panikartig abgereist weshalb
infektionsketten nicht angemessen
nachverfolgt werden konnten
überhaupt habe es keinen
evakuierungsplan gegeben
die vergiftung des kremlkritikers
navalny mit dem nerven kampfstoff
naughty dog hat in ganz europa für
entsetzen gesorgt
jetzt ist sich die eu einig und verhängt
strafmaßnahmen gegen russische
regierungsvertreter und wegen der
anhaltenden gewalt in belarus gegen
friedliche demonstranten sollen die
sanktionen dort nun auch auf machthaber
lukaschenko ausgeweitet werden ina
baltes massive polizeigewalt gegen
friedliche demonstranten
es sind diese immer wiederkehrenden
bilder aus minsk die die eu jetzt
handeln lassen
dabei wird der belarussische staatschef
von den eu-außenministern heute in
luxemburg persönlich ins visier genommen
sie geben grünes licht für die
vorbereitungen von sanktionen gegen
lukaschenko und seine familie
wir müssen feststellen dass seit der
letzten sitzung nichts besser geworden
ist die gewalt geht weiter die ausgeübt
wird vom lukaschenko regime
es gibt nach wie vor verhaftungen von
friedliebenden demonstranten geschlossen
zeigt sich die runde auch im fall alexej
nawalny russland wird mit neuen
sanktionen belegt der kreml-kritiker
hält sich derzeit in berlin auf mit dem
giftanschlag auf ihn so die
außenminister sei eindeutig gegen das
chemie werfen verbot verstoßen worden
grußworte des leider gottes verabsäumt
die chancen zu nutzen zur aufklärung des
attentats beizutragen
da kann europäischen nicht einfach zur
tagesordnung übergehen
zu dieser eklatanten verletzung des
verbots dass einsätze von chemiewaffen
am ende gibt es wohl einreiseverboten
und kontosperren für rund zehn russische
offizielle auch wenn noch wochen
vergehen werden bis alle sanktionen in
kraft treten das signal aus luxemburg
ist klar
abwarten und zusehen das führt nicht
weiter
nach dem mutmaßlich illegalen autorennen
mit einem unbeteiligten todesopfer auf
der a66 bei frankfurt ermittelt nun die
staatsanwaltschaft wegen mordes
drei männer sollen sich am samstag mit
ihrem sportwagen ein rennen
haben dabei verlor einer der fahrer
offenbar die kontrolle und kollidierte
mit einem auto eine frau darin starb
zwei der sportwagenfahrer nahmen die
polizei bereits fest nach dem dritten
wird noch gefahndet
im hochsicherheitstrakt des düsseldorfer
oberlandesgerichts hat heute eine der
größten mafia prozesse deutschlands
begonnen
14 mutmaßliche mitglieder der
kalabrischen ndrangheta müssen sich
unter anderem wegen geldwäsche und
drogenhandels verantworten
noch bevor die anklage verlesen werden
konnte wurde der prozess wieder
unterbrochen grund ein beschuldigter ist
in corona quarantäne sein testergebnis
liegt noch nicht vor
frühestens am freitag soll es
weitergehen
heute ist die polarstern zurückgekehrt
mit 101 menschen an bord von der bislang
größten arktis-expedition aller zeiten
das deutsche forschungsschiff
ausgerüstet mit neuester technik war ein
jahr unterwegs seine mission daten
sammeln damit die wissenschaftler besser
verstehen wie der klimawandel die arktis
verändert startpunkt der reise war traum
sie in norwegen
das ziel der nordpol der weg dahin
ungewöhnlich das forscherteam folgte
keiner festen route sondern ließ sich
absichtlich an eine scholle festfrieren
und driftete so mehrere monate durch die
arktis aus bremerhaven kai niklasch
[Musik]
großer bahnhof in bremerhaven bei der
rückkehr der polarstern nach über einem
jahr begleitet von einer schiffsflotte
herbei gesehen von familie und kollegen
die verantwortlichen erleichtert über
die sichere heimkehr mit an bord
erkenntnisse von wissenschaftlern aus 20
ländern
ich freue mich einfach wahnsinnig dass
jetzt unser schiff wieder da ist mit all
den leuten es ist ja über ein jahr her
dass ich es so live gesehen habe ich
jetzt hier um die ecke gebogen ist und
zu wissen dass alle heil nach hause
gekommen sind und mit solchen
gigantischen schätzen an daten und
proben das ist doch ein ganz tolles
gefühl mit einer riesigen scholle
driftete die polarstern durch den
arktischen winter bis zu 23 kilometer
pro tag forscher worten tief ins eis
kerne zu entnehmen schickten sonden ins
meer und ließen wetterballons aufsteigen
eine erkenntnis der lebensraum der
eisbären schrumpft weiterhin dramatisch
welt ist bedroht wir haben wirklich
gesehen wie das eis verschwindet
wir haben nördlich von grünland weite
flächen offenen wasser vorgefunden in
einem bereich von normalerweise dickes
zum teil mehrjähriges eis liegen sollte
und sogar am pool selbst ist das eis
völlig aufgeschmolzen marode und von
schmerzen punktegleichheit gewesen wenn
wir so weitermachen dann wird die arktis
im sommer in wenigen jahrzehnten eisfrei
sein und diese welt die ich gerade
beschrieben haben nicht mehr existieren
schlechte nachrichten also nicht nur für
eisbären in diesem jahr war das meereis
in der arktis auf die zweitkleinste
fläche geschrumpft die je gemessen wurde
nur eine der dramatischen erkenntnisse
die das forschungsschiff mitbringt die
us ökonom robert wilson und paul milgram
erhalten in diesem jahr den nobelpreis
für wirtschaftswissenschaften
die forscher beschäftigen sich mit
auktionen eine der häufigsten
verkaufsform überhaupt ihre arbeit
hätten theorie und praxis der auktion
auf der ganzen welt wesentlich
vorangebracht so die königlich
schwedische akademie der wissenschaften
noch ein gewinner genau genauer eine
gewinnerin ist in frankfurt am main
geehrt worden
alle weber erhält in diesem jahr den
deutschen buchpreis
annett ein heldenepos heißt ihr werk
es erzählt vom leben
einer französischen widerstandskämpferin
während des zweiten weltkriegs die
ehrung findet wie jedes jahr im
kaisersaal des römers statt allerdings
man ahnt es unter corona bedingungen
linken klinge in diesem jahr ist vieles
anders
der saal nur spärlich gefüllt die
spannung trotzdem groß anne weber und
auch die freude bei der gewinnerin den
deutschen buchpreis bekommt anne weber
für ein ungewöhnliches werk sie hat als
form ein epos in versen gewählt wie in
der antike ein heldenepos für uns war
wirklich das ganz großartige daran dass
man eigentlich erst denkt das ist eine
unfassbare sperrige idee und dann stellt
sich aber heraus dass man beim lesen den
eindruck gewinnt dass man das gar nicht
anders erzählen könnte die heldin annett
bohmann ua die autorin ist ihre
hauptfigur zufällig begegnet vor einiger
zeit und war fasziniert die heute
96-jährige annett hat ihr leben dem
streben nach einer besseren welt
gewidmet
sie stammt aus einem kleinen fischerdorf
an der bretonischen küste
ihre eltern sind überzeugte kommunisten
im zweiten weltkrieg rettet die junge
annett juden das leben und riskiert
dabei ihr eigenes später schließt sie
sich dem kampf für die unabhängigkeit
algeriens von frankreich an wird so zur
terroristin dass man menschen töten
für ein bestimmtes ziel 6 sehr
unterschiedliche bücher inhaltlich und
stilistisch haben es in diesem jahr in
die endauswahl geschafft schon allein
durch die nominierung erhalten sie alle
besondere aufmerksamkeit macht neugierig
und zum sport und zur deutschen
fußball-nationalmannschaft jetzt endlich
weiß wie sich ein sieg in der nations
league anfühlt an den 2 1 erfolg vom
samstag in kiew gegen die ukraine
anknüpfen
das will teamchef joachim löw morgen
abend in köln drei punkte beim spiel
gegen die schweiz sind pflicht die
kölner zuschauer müssen morgen corona
bedingt alle zu hause bleiben wenn die
mannschaft die auf der anderen
rheinseite ihr abgeschirmtes quartier
bezogen hat zum dritten spiel innerhalb
einer woche antritt was ich gegen die
schweiz erwarte ist sicherlich auch
konzentration
ich erwarte natürlich auch in unserem
spiel mehr präzision
da haben wir sicherlich ein paar fehler
gemacht der 2 1-erfolg letzten samstag
in kiew war der erste sieg in der vor
zwei jahren eingeführten nations league
hinter draxler halstenberg und
klostermann stehen noch fragezeichen
toni kroos wird mitglied im club der
hunderter bestreitet morgen in köln sein
100 länderspiel für deutschland
die los angeles lakers sind zum
siebzehnten mal nba champion das team um
basketball superstar lebron james gewann
mit 4 2 in der finalserie gegen miami
heat im todesjahr der klub ikone kobe
bryant eine ganz besondere meisterschaft
für mannschaft und fans die emotionen
einer ganzen saison müssen jetzt raus
meisterschaft nummer sie
18 ist eine besondere wir wussten dieses
mal für kobe und die lakers nation
gewinnen das ist ein spezieller titel
lakers-legende kobe bryant war anfang
des jahres bei einem hubschrauberabsturz
ums leben gekommen
dann kam auch noch corona 1 k saniert in
disney world spielten die teams wie in
einer großen blase
doch draußen protestierte die black lips
matter bewegung und die spieler
solidarisierten sich streik es war eine
außergewöhnliche saison für die liga und
für die lakers
das corona mit der meisterschaft nicht
verschwindet haben viele fans im taumel
offenbar verdrängt viele aber nicht alle
so kann man sich natürlich auch schützen
während unsere flure zu eng dafür ganze
42 millionen euro gewinnt eine
lottospielerin aus baden württemberg
rekord was könnte man dafür kaufen
etwa diesen diamantring zwei millionen
hätte man sogar noch über vielleicht für
eine gute alarmanlage
apropos edle steine warum nicht mal die
rolling stones mieten acht auftritte
gibt es angeblich für das geld höher
hinaus mit spacex ins all
dazu fehlen weitere 40 millionen kein
problem einfach nochmal im lotto
gewinnen tja diese sorgen möchte man
haben nach neben scheint morgen auf die
sonne
zur wochenmitte kommen von osten her
sturm und regen mehr zum wetter gleich
von katja honnefer das war es von uns
das heute journal um 21.45 mit marietta
slomka
wir sagen danke für ihre aufmerksamkeit
wünschen noch einen angenehmen abend und
sehen uns morgen wieder hoffe ich
tschüss
[Musik]
meine damen und herren drei fragen
beschäftigung zweiter beim wetter
erstens haben sie schon winterreifen
zweitens wie viel regen fällt am
mittwoch im osten deutschlands und
drittens wie kräftig wird der sturm an
der ostsee am mittwoch der schlüssel für
all diese fragen das ist dieses tief
dass ich hier gerade über der adria ein
kringelt das bringt kräftige regen
wolken aus südosteuropa auch zu uns aber
nicht in dieser nacht da ist es meist
klar und es bildet sich zum teil dichter
nebel mit sichtweiten unter 150 meter an
den alpen fällt ein bisschen regen und
das ist nicht ganz ungefährlich denn die
temperaturen sinken doch verbreitet auf
plus 4 bis minus 1 grad
es droht also bodenfrost und dann kann
es eben glatz seien auf den strassen
morgen liegen dann nämlich temperaturen
zwischen 6 grad an den alpen und 14 grad
zum beispiel in der lüneburger heide am
vormittag gibt es noch häufig nebel
da tut sich die sonne erst mal schwer
und hier an der donau fällt etwas regen
der nebel löst sich dann bis zum
nachmittag auf dann aber kommen schon
diese regenwolken hier von polen an
und dann wird es gefährlich am mittwoch
denn da droht kräftiger dauerregen 30
bis 60 liter regen so etwa zwischen
berlin und dem erzgebirge und an der
ostsee gibt es nicht nur strom sondern
wahrscheinlich auch eine sturmflut
schöner